America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
I was going to put him
[Music]
I was gonna put him
hello Internet I'm Dave Rubin and by the
looks of it I'm still in Washington DC
that's right we are in the swamp this is
day two uh yesterday on top of doing our
regular show we also interviewed
Congressman Dan Crenshaw Congressman
Matt Gates and Senator Ron Johnson we've
got a long slew of interviews coming up
today including a interview at the
Capitol in front of a studio audience is
it a studio if we're not really in a
studio a room full of people our local
subscribers about 100 people are joining
us at the Capitol as I sit down uh with
Kevin McCarthy this afternoon then we're
going to take a tour of the capital
wander around the mall uh that is going
to be fun then we're having drinks at an
undisclosed location probably tequila
and then more interviews tomorrow and uh
as of this taping still not one Democrat
has responded to us but we'll keep
trying in case you forgot we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you have not subscribed go ahead and
do that and then just because of our
crazy schedule today there will be no
post game show so let's get right into
it we've got just a quick start and then
we're going to get into a Community Q a
uh Joe Biden he was up in Canada for a
couple days and he sat down with Justin
Trudeau and tell me when you watch this
video does it say confidence or what
what a real pleasure it is to welcome
President Biden to uh to Ottawa back to
Ottawa it's so great to see you Joe
obviously we've been working closely
together over the past few years on how
to build strong economies for everyone
in our two countries and around the
world how to continue our fight against
climate change and prepare a stronger
economic future for everyone but also
how we deal with uh changing you know I
said to Phoenix right before we started
are we being a little heavy-handed by
showing this video obviously we always
show the videos of him fumbling and
stumbling and falling up the stairs and
not knowing which way he's going and all
that but you know okay he's going
through the notes but then it hit me
it's like no we're not being
heavy-handed because if that guy had not
found the note card you know he fumbles
through the papers then he gets the note
card and on the note card it literally
you know they've they've taken pictures
of his note cards before it literally
tells him who he's sitting next to what
their position is who he can call on
what question he's going to answer in
effect without that piece of paper uh he
ain't much he ain't much but a face
pulled back dentured weirdo and that is
a bit of a problem nobody really has
confidence that this is the guy in
charge of the ship and look I know and a
whole bunch of you have said it I've
been critical of trump lately but Trump
like him hate him doesn't matter he can
get up there and command a room and he
knows what he's talking about and he
knows who he's talking to and he knows
what he believes and everything else
this is a major problem when the leader
of any country especially uh the one
remaining superpower at least for now uh
really barely knows what he is doing and
he just doesn't but the hits continued
as he wandered around he met Pierre
polavier who is the leader of the uh
conservative party it's the opposition
party because obviously the Liberals and
Justin Trudeau are in charge of Canada
he was Joe Biden was doing in a couple
handshakes you know the little line
where they do the handshakes and they
had this very awkward moment
just because
leader of his Majesty's loyal opposition
we believe that opposition is an act of
loyalty in our system
again I might be a little heavy-handed
here but we do too unfortunately but
then the way he walked away as he said
unfortunately like he didn't finish the
joke and it's like he doesn't really
believe in opposition right what is he
calling all of us these days uh is he
calling us loyal opposition or just
principled opposition or say just
Republicans no everyone's a what is it a
hardcore Ultra Maga extremist that crazy
speech that he gave with like the
hitler-like background and the red and
the black and the fist boundary
but this is what Joe Biden is and of
course no compilation of Joe Biden would
be complete without him getting lost
[Music]
targeting Americans does there need to
be a higher cost sir
that's your president everybody and I
guess he is mine too a man who doesn't
know where he is without the notes a man
who makes a thinly veiled joke about
totalitarian control to the opposition
leader in Canada and a guy who doesn't
know which way to walk off stage God
bless him but okay let's do one nuts and
bolts thing about him today about actual
policy because you know I like to
Enlighten you too and not just go for
the low brow stuff I saw this tweet by
Biden and of course it's not by Biden
someone else writes him he doesn't hold
his phone he doesn't even know what they
tweet but here we go Maga house
Republican proposals would slash funding
for border security A Move That Could
allow nearly 900 pounds of fentanyl into
our country we need more resources to
secure the Border not less it is so guys
it is so extraordinary that whoever his
handlers are even have the gall to talk
about the border and Fentanyl the amount
of fentanyl that has crossed across the
border under Biden Administration is
record pacing as are all of the border
crossings in general you know humans
actually crossing the border and then
God knows where they go unless they go
to Martha's Vineyard in which case
everyone's going to know about it and
we're going to get rid of them real
quick uh but yes we have a massive
massive fentanyl problem in the United
States go to any big city I mean for
those of you that are on Twitter God
bless you what are you doing with your
life I mean the videos that you can see
on any given day obviously San Francisco
obviously Los Angeles but every blue
City Philadelphia I saw some really
horrific videos out of Portland Seattle
you know the list so if you're concerned
about that you would be sealing the
Border immediately the idea that it's
the Republicans fault the Republicans
who by the way are not in charge of the
White House one of the few duties of the
White House is to protect the border the
idea that it's their fault that the
fentanyl is getting across the fentanyl
doesn't just magically appear fentanyl
doesn't just you know fabricate out of
nothing right Dental comes a guy's got
it in the bag and he comes and he brings
it over and then they sell it or they
give it away actually a lot of times
they're giving it away to destroy these
communities or get people hooked
initially whatever it might be and that
he has the gall again he doesn't know
what he's doing or that he didn't
actually put the Tweet up to pretend
that this is the Republican's fault is
just lunacy but that's why a guy like me
is here in the swamp that's why I'm here
in DC chatting with as many people as I
can talk to because the system is screwy
it ain't working properly but maybe we
can sign maybe we can shine some light
on some of the people that can course
correct this thing I think particularly
I I've enjoyed all of the interviews so
far but my interview with Senator Ron
Johnson who I've never had on the show
before I thought was really really good
I mean this guy he holds no punches
whether he's going after fauci or Biden
or anybody uh I think you're you're
gonna dig that you're gonna dig them all
I promise you there will be a lot of
digging and on that note let's get to
the Reuben report locals.com Community Q
a crafty says after listening to the
house committee last week on the
testimony of the CEO of tick tock there
was damaging evidence that Tick Tock
that the tick tock app should be banned
in the U.S what are your thoughts on
this have a great time in DC
look let's put aside Tick Tock for one
second then I'll address that
specifically we know
that this thing which we pretty much all
have in our pocket all the time is
checking I don't know spying isn't even
necessarily the right word at some point
because we kind of all know it right we
sign up for apps you click accept you
should have a lawyer but they know that
most of us don't have a lawyer on
retainer going oh did you download an
app I better look through that terms of
service we we give it all away the idea
that all of these things are free that
Twitter is free and Facebook is free and
YouTube is free they're not free we're
the product our data our click habits
our viewing habits how they can
manipulate us how they can push ads one
way what video they can show you so they
can manipulate even what you think about
politics are there weeks and months that
go by that my videos don't show up in
your feed at all and then suddenly out
of nowhere you're like boy I have seen a
lot of Dave lately I'm sick of that guy
but then you don't see me for months
after that like there are so many ways
we are being manipulated and doom
scrolling right websites used to get to
an end remember the old days you'd go to
espn.com you'd read a couple stories
little football a little basketball a
little baseball you'd scroll down it
would get to the end then they removed
that right and it became endless scroll
and the guy who invented endless scroll
I've seen some interviews with him he
regrets it because it created this
situation where our brains are always
going and going and going as for tick
tock specifically
we know they're collecting data on us it
is a Chinese spyware app that's that's
basically the simplest way to describe
it the the clips that I saw of The Tick
Tock CEO were not impressive I mean he
basically said that the government of
China pretty much can influence uh their
ability to collect data like if in
essence that if they uh have data the
Chinese government is allowed to just go
in no questions asked and and take the
data force them to give up the data but
we have this AOC doesn't want to get rid
of it
um it's it's not good but look our own
government is doing it to us on American
apps so
I would say it sort of is what it is
uh one other thing on that though I
would also say if Tick Tock just
disappeared tomorrow would probably be
better for everybody but you know look
apps are tools you could use like
anything else the internet's a tool you
can use it for good you can use it for
evil the choice is yours uh prosky says
how did your talk at University of
Wisconsin at Green Bay go it was
excellent it was really great you know
because of the kids obviously I haven't
done a ton of travel here I am in DC at
the moment but I've been scaling back
for the last year or so and then covered
before that on on College gigs and I
forgot how much I missed them I really
really enjoyed it there was a nice
little private uh cocktail hour first
chatted with some folks and it you know
it's nice also especially to go to the
middle of the country and just chat with
people what's on their mind and when I
you know I talked with people about what
they thought about the the Trump
DeSantis brouhaha and just talk about
life what do people do I talked to a
couple professors about the temperature
on campus one thing that consistently
came up with several professors that I
talked to is that kids are just a afraid
to say what they think I was talking to
an accounting professor and he's like
kids in my class won't even raise their
hands anymore they used to I used but
now I have to force them I have to call
on them individually because nobody
raises their hands anymore that's that's
pretty chilling but the Talk itself was
really enjoyable you know I the one
thing that I don't have on a day-to-day
basis is the is the live audience thing
and I do miss that and we're thinking
about some things in the future to make
that happen a little bit more either on
the road or or maybe a studio in Miami
so hang tight on that but it but it was
good to be out there again it was really
nice to meet a couple of you from the
locals Community who came on down uh
Miss mama panda says hi Dave would it be
possible
to do a locals Community get together
and visit the rumble HQ studio in
Sarasota that would be so cool so first
off I definitely want to do more
get-togethers in general we are doing
one tonight in Washington DC near the
capitol it is for local subscribers only
uh if you're here in DC doing this event
with us all day you already know about
it but I will post the location for
subscribers only a little bit later
tonight we'll have some drinks and maybe
some apps and just say hi and shoot the
as they say and uh and enjoy the
evening but yeah I want to do more in
Florida for sure Sarasota is absolutely
gorgeous uh the rumble offices and
studios are really really fantastic and
they do they're right on the water there
and they've they've got like a pretty
great event space so let me see what I
can do about that I will add it to the
list Phoenix add it to the list it's
been added to the list Florida man Chuck
says what would you say to Nikki Haley's
comments regarding DeSantis just
following what Trump is doing from
everything I I've seen it actually
appears to be the other way around I
know you did not object when she said it
but I'm curious if it caught you off
guard you know it's interesting I think
you could probably argue this one either
way I remember the exact moment that
you're referring to in my interview with
her from a week or two ago where she's
saying that DeSantis is replicating a
lot of the Trump stuff you know it does
seem like on some hand on the other hand
you could look at Trump and be like well
he's just jumping in on all the woke
stuff now and he's jumping in on the
critical race Theory stuff and like
there's you know even he hasn't done too
much on ESG but he does talk about China
a lot I don't even think it matters
really to me if you have good policy
the question is who can execute that
policy the best who has the vision and
then are you able to actually
communicate that vision and get
something done about it so if Trump had
to say this and this is this is another
reason I've been I've been sort of more
annoyed with Trump lately
if you guys agree on let's say 90 of the
stuff and I think that they probably do
if you really whittled it down they
agree on 90 of the policy then the goal
should not be to be destroying each
other it you should be making the
argument saying this is why I am the
best person to be president to get these
things done so it doesn't matter you
know if someone has great policy if
there's a politician out there here
let's do it this way in my opinion Ron
DeSantis has fantastic policies
obviously I've seen that firsthand in
Florida and as I always tell you he's
Blueprinting that across the country
right now and we see it happening School
of Choice in other states fighting ESG
and other states Etc
if people want to copy that that's
pretty great and I think he'd be
thrilled if Rhonda Sanders woke up and
he was like boy 37 states have copied my
woke policies my ESG policy they're
lowering taxes uh they're doing
infrastructure projects faster et cetera
et cetera I think he'd think it was
great now Trump on the ego level might
have he would want more credit for it or
something like that he'd want them to
put you know Donald J Trump at the
bottom of it but I don't care who came
up with the stuff first the question is
who can accomplish this stuff and who
can communicate it properly so more
people get on board and I think clearly
you know what my answer is on that one
Sonny says Dave how have your views on
the world changed after having kids was
Jordan Peterson right you know Jordan
and Tammy came over for dinner last week
and it was the first time that Jordan
got to to meet the kids and Justin my
oldest his middle name is Jordan in
honor of Jordan and I we had called
Jordan and Tammy on we did it on video
and I didn't want to do it without his
his Blessing and of course he was
thrilled and I can I think I can say
this Jordan had couple tiers every now
and again he does and I even teared up
too which is rare
um or at least certainly rarer than
Jordan
um I think well it's changed everything
it's changed everything like it changes
like the obvious stuff like my
day-to-day is very different waking up
with kids and changing diapers and being
spit up on uh Luke pooped all over me
the other day I know I've mentioned this
a couple times because it's happened a
few times but I got a picture I'll show
it to the guys later we're not going to
post it on the internet but like it was
insane explosion but that's not I'm sort
of being silly about that stuff
um
it's what I've said before on one hand
which is just like I have an extra
reason to fight
it's not just about me anymore it's not
just about David anymore like I haven't
and my family
meaning my family that I came from
there's an extra reason to fight and
that that's important but I would say
also there's something else it's like
you can see
it's all it's almost like you could see
the future in these kids eyes you know
what I mean they are so open to the
world uh uh Justin's just starting to
eat some solid foods like they're so at
the beginning of everything that it it
like renews you in a way I think I'm I'm
actually better at this job that I'm
doing because of it I think I'm a better
person because of it and that's that's
like a wild thing that you really I
can't even explain it properly right now
like it just is but any of you who are
out there that are parents probably get
it uh Dragonfire says whatever happened
to needing 60 votes in the Senate only
needing 51 votes does not promote
working together and compromising yes
and do you know who you have to blame
for this shocker it's the Democrats you
may remember around 2014 the Democrats
use the nuclear option remember Harry
Reid was in charge Harry Reid just one
of those names that everyone knew and
now he's he's gone he forced the nuclear
options so that the Senate could pass
things with 51 a mere majority as
opposed to the 60 the the super majority
you can find video I don't recommend you
do it but I promise you you can find it
when I was a lefty I was a progressive I
was on The Young Turks and that was
happening and they were all thrilled
about it because it was going to mean
that the Democrats were going to have
more power and you I promise you this is
out there you can find video of me
saying we better be careful what we ask
for right now because this will be used
against the Democrats you don't want to
change the system just because you have
the power to do so because that means
the other guys are going to do it too
and you are completely right this is a
huge problem coupled with the fact that
now you know with the Democrat
Administration the Thai vote in case of
a tie is the vice president and that's
Kamala I mean Jesus so uh blame Harry
Reid Google Harry read nuclear option
and you can find all about I'm pretty
sure it was uh my guess is it was
probably fall of 2014 if I'm not
mistaken Richard says will you ask every
Congress person and Senator if they
support legislation forcing all members
of Congress Congress the cabinet and
White House Executives to be banned from
any investment trading of stocks Futures
Commodities while serving and have their
portfolios held in a blind trust making
it a federal felony crime they should be
held to the standard that we have
legislated for Wall Street well I'm
pretty sure that I just saw Matt Gates
walk in so I'm going to do this show
quick and I'm going to make sure that I
ask him that very question in about 15
minutes so stay tuned on that one and
I'll try to ask it to everyone else but
I haven't but yes term limits and
figuring out how these people don't walk
out millionaires while they come in you
know with next to nothing is a major
issue somehow usually the Democrats but
the Republicans have done pretty well uh
in that department as well Sam says why
is the GOP messaging so bad why are we
not advertising GOP successes over
Democrat failures you know one of the
reasons is that because
as you know Andrew Breitbart said
politics is Downstream from culture
we're always fighting up when when
you've got Hollywood when you've got big
Tech when you've got music and art and
comedy now a lot of this stuff is
changing but when you have the
superstructure of that we're always
fighting against it and they're always
kind of moving on it and it's this ever
growing amorphous blob I really do think
that's changing I mean there's no
there's what's funny coming out of the
left when's the last time you heard some
good new music right like like in this
bizarre time that we live in where
everything seems to be sort of so
politically correct and everyone's so
afraid to say what they think you can't
create in that and I think that's
actually starting to change which is why
Joe Rogan's funny Dave Chappelle is
funny like the edginess is now coming
out of people it's not that they're
conservative per se it's not they're
Republicans I certainly don't think
either one of those guys consider
themselves a republican but they're not
a woke leftist and that's pretty good
that means you're somewhat culture
Counter Culture uh Nick says has anyone
ever told you that David kind of looks
like a young Tom Hanks uh the
resemblance is astounding this is
totally Gonna Change Forrest Gump for me
I will look into that and see what's
what uh Elisa says Bibi Netanyahu and
his right-wing legislators won their
election on a platform of reforming
their judicial system that has evolved
into a left-wing cabal that governs From
the Bench well-funded left-wing
protesters are terrorizing Israel
funding and organizing comes from abroad
does anyone have the courage to
acknowledge BB's courage and wish him
the best you know it's interesting
because just as we're starting this show
I'm seeing a whole bunch of things that
it sounds like BB may be reversing
course on some of these judicial reforms
we haven't covered it too much but we
are doing I think I hinted at this a
couple weeks ago we are doing an
international trip coming up end of
April into May we're doing Israel and
Hungary I'm hoping that we can sit down
with Bibi again obviously I did it a
couple months ago and hoping that we can
sit down with Orban in in Hungary
um
he's backed off a little bit so why
don't I just leave it there and we'll
we'll hit this up more later in the week
Elizabeth says who is your favorite
Founding Father I've answered this one a
couple times you know my I always go to
Thomas Jefferson
for a couple reasons but I think the
main one is that you can go to his house
in Virginia Monticello and it's not even
a house I mean it's it's an incredible
estate and you can take a tour where
they go through the Brilliance of Thomas
Jefferson this man who was literally
writing the laws to free the slaves as
he was still a slave owner and had
relations with slaves but he was he was
writing aspirational documents that that
freed people that were maybe better than
he was as a man and that's what we all
are right like we can all believe in
things that are that are Beyond us and
and try to be better and and he did so
many I mean he was an incredible
inventor and when they even show you how
he created you know they didn't have uh
electricity like how he created this
unbelievable uh freezing unit
underground so that he could have ice in
the middle of the summer in Virginia
like the guy was a true genius I think
it goes without saying but you should
check it out if you've never been there
a couple more Deborah says uh what's
going on with the sen Senators that are
Mia seems very secretive fetterman
McConnell Feinstein we really need term
limits yes we need term limits two terms
and you gotta go you don't have to go
home but you can't stay here uh yes that
would be good fetterman I don't know
what's going on apparently there was a
picture of him that came out in the last
couple days but it's like is this
shocking like is anyone shocked by this
nobody even cared for a month which
tells you a little something Dianne
Feinstein she's 162 years old no one's
seen her in forever but I guess she
finally said she's not going to run
again yeah we need Ed McConnell you know
he fell I guess and hurt his leg
how about some younger people I'm not an
ageist The Golden Girls is one of my
favorite shows okay I loved cocoon but
we need some people in their 30s and 40s
and 50s people who are in their Prime of
their life who understand a new world
and a world that we're going to as
opposed to just having geriatric people
like we have in the White House who
don't know what's going on enough enough
enough
Amanda says I've heard some people say
they think DeSantis is a deep state
plant why would they think that what has
he done that aligns with the Deep State
I don't know you know these people that
keep saying he's a rhino or a globalist
it's like I don't know the guy's done
everything that I could have asked to
someone that loves freedom in Florida
right I mean we kept the state open
we've kept taxes low we've got low
unemployment low crime like things are
working we're fighting ESG fighting the
woke so it's like if that's what the
Deep state is planting on us then I
guess we got to get the Deep State uh
some credit uh Amy Says have you
traveled with the boys yet if so how did
it go if not are you waiting until their
specific age we've taken them to the uh
local Botanical Gardens and to the
petting zoo that's as far as we've gone
so far uh but yeah I think maybe or you
know they're just at the age where it
feels like a little more okay to be
getting them in the car and getting them
out there but Disney will not be the
first trip how about that rocking world
says how can I navigate the waters when
one of my close friends is very far left
yet I am on the right I'm hesitant to
talk about anything about politics
because I don't want to seem fake
especially now in recent months where
everything's so polarized
it's a great question to end on look you
know I've discussed versions of this
before what you will consistently find
is that if your friend is far left and
you're on the right and let's just say
you're a complete moderate
you probably don't think politics is
everything but they probably do by
definition and if you're going out of
your way not to tell your friend what
you think or not to debate as something
that's on your mind at some point that
doesn't become a friendship a
friendship's a two-way street that you
can hopefully over time through
conversation and arguing and laughing
and having a drink and shooting the
and all of that stuff that you can
actually better each other and at some
point as the years go by if you're like
boy you know I've got this friend who I
don't really tell what's on my mind we
don't really talk about anything
important I'm kind of skirting the issue
all the time you might just realize boy
that turns out that's not the friend I
call that often because it's not that
everything has to be about politics I
would actually say the reverse but but
friendship is based in mutual respect
and unfortunately with the with the
lefties it is freaking tough on that
note I know I spoke very fast but Mac
Yates is standing right there and I
think his hair is higher than mine today
so we're gonna have to Duke it out
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
play along during the show my full
episode with Dan Crenshaw is up right
now I leave you with the cold clothes
and we'll see you tomorrow the Second
Amendment from the day it was passed
limited the type of people could own a
gun
what type of weapon you could own you
couldn't buy a cannon
Moses say the blood of the the blood of
patriots you know
move against the government
well the tree of Liberty is not watering
the blood of patriots what's happened is
that there never been if you wanted to
think you need to have weapons to take
on the government you need f-15s there
may be some nuclear weapons
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foreign